what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation look who's in town Sally lamanako is
here with us today I still get my name wrong
Sally's visiting I was like well why hang
out we should shoot a movie reaction together
I gotta participate in her uh Spider-Man Mary
Jane short film we shot something for it keep
a lookout for that it'll be out in six to
eight years I'm really excited for it I believe
in you thank you six to eight years is a good
amount of time to get your 10 minute short
film done it's gonna be like 30 minutes guys
that's a long short film I know you should
make it 10 minutes well then I'll have to
cut you out though you should make it 30 minutes
hey leave a like cause Sally's in town right
yeah yeah just please leave a like if I get
to 500 likes I'll move back to L.A so ambitious
no why are you crossing your arms are you
uncomfortable no I'm itching my arm all right
okay my arms making sure I can't read your
body language
copy of Roger Pitch Perfect that's why we
said yeah I didn't even mention that we've
never seen it just so happened to be wearing
a shirt that is a great song there you go
so patreon we have for our super sexy rejects
where you stick up with your own copy of Pitch
Perfect we could watch the whole thing with
us we also got exclusive content as well oh
yeah uh Sally's uh she's not doing the Marvel
reactions here anymore let's roll that intro
I'm getting chewed out for and my DMs are
like well you couldn't even commit to doing
this yeah what's your problem I'm like listen
I was shooting them all really fast and I
was on it correct the one that's like let's
hold this there's a hole Yeah you deserve
it I have to lead this Channel and it's important
that the leader never takes blame right and
only points to everyone else right that is
what you learned from 21 irrefutable laws
of leadership let's roll that intro
from me
is that an acapella yeah I have no clue what
this movie's about it's just about singing
I have zero idea I assume it's called pitch
perfect please don't stop them please don't
stop though please don't stop the music I
love acapella now this is exactly the type
of performance you would expect to see at
the International Championship I didn't know
she was in this nothing makes a woman feel
more like a girl than a man who sings like
a boy
look at you you're a mess you're unfocused
you dumb [__] my dad always says if you're
not here to win get the hell out of Kuwait
has your dad ever told you to shut up yeah
I'm on her side team Selena please don't stop
the music boy that hurts sexy man split his
pain is our game Gail [Laughter]
is this movie about acapella yes it's acapella
groups oh no way yeah [Music] it's a horrible
song [Music] oh this is cool I love this I'm
turning a snoozeville yeah and we park in
a lot where they do not validate [Laughter]
[Music]
that was nasty we know exactly where it is
[Music] yeah this movie has Style [Music]
I love Anna Kendrick
[Laughter]
this guy looks so familiar there he is oh
there's been plaid I love Ben wow looking
at it now I can see that it's a bit much I
could take it down no it's Michael Tessler
just uh it's your old man making a funny Chris
Rock everybody that
DJing is not a profession it's a hobby I want
to produce music I want to make music you're
going to get a college education first for
free I would not have this conversation like
in front of someone yeah so drop that you're
getting a free college education [Applause]
Dane Cook yes I was gonna say he looks like
a young version of Dane Cook troublemakers
of acapella
how's your voice [Music] oh nice
it's an awkward thing I am confident that
we will find eight super hot girls with bikini
ready bodies who can harmonize in a perfect
pitch okay oh this is gonna be a great movie
this is try me
[Music]
call yourself Fat Amy yes so twig [__]
let you know behind my back
diff juice that's not a real word but keep
trying you will get there
laughs
there's four groups on campus the Bellas that's
us the bu harmonics they sing a lot of Madonna
the high notes they're not particularly motivated
I get it are we sing all over the world and
we compete in National Championships on purpose
we played the Cobb Energy Performing Arts
Center you [__] oh wow and bumper huge
fan the smell of your weird is actually affecting
my vocal cord so I'm gonna need you to
what a dick it's like acapella gangs yeah
it's like West Side Story yeah
Annie has an accent my God yes I know I'm
Luke station manager you must be Becky the
intern um it's uh hey man what's up I'm Jesse
I'm Luke you're late I know you no you don't
no you don't now you guys will be spending
a lot of down time together so please just
no sex on the desk I've been burned before
what a shitty rule one of those girls is all
dark and mysterious and she takes off her
glasses and that amazingly scary ear Spike
and you realize that you know she was beautiful
the whole time no more glasses then you're
halfway there oh oh dick
out of here jokes aren't even funny it was
a compliment he was saying you're hot no you
were saying you were half hot get a little
let me mansplain this to you I just always
get mad at me I got a job at the radio station
oh great that place yeah it's dark and dirty
and has like what those three weirdos who
work there well four now how do you know that
he had sex on that table
the toast you can sing you have to audition
for the fellas you were seeing titanium right
you know David Guetta have I been living under
a rock everyone knows that song yeah I'm leaving
here until you sing so this is problematic
so weird cancel Pitch Perfect so I'm tired
[Music]
and then they fall in love Yeah start making
out that's why everyone loves this movie [Music]
they're making strong eye contact no they
have really good chemistry yeah lovely voice
thanks
see you at audition what in bars of Kelly
Clarkson Since You've Been Gone if a group
likes you Christopher mint plazas in this
WOW Nick Lovin here's some things [Music]
it was cool but it was all pretend and yeah
yeah it's like theater kid 100 I'm sorry what
was that fish [Laughter] say [Music] [Applause]
[Music] s
dude the editing in this is great yeah it
is
[Music] [Applause] [Music] [Applause] oh he
was the guy in that musical movie that people
didn't like [Music] but he also won like Tony's
for that so I'm aware he's got great like
solo music that I love I didn't know we had
to prepare that song oh that's okay sing anything
you want uh man oh yeah the cup thing what
cup thing have you seen this no but like it's
a trend
got my ticket for the long way round
ah that is cool when I'm gone dude prettiest
I was falling in love with her I know you're
gonna miss me when I'm gone
damn that caught me nipple chill
[Music] Colt that Amy Denise Ashley and Becca
wow it's like a cult that's what I just said
I don't listen to you
classic pun I know [Music] Benji he's with
the Enemy promise to never have sexual relations
with the Troublemaker or
[Music] did I get you a drink sounds great
I'm gonna get you a drink go for it I think
you need to get on this level do you want
to have your vocal cords ripped out by Wolves
I think she does I mean she was in Twilight
so she's kind of familiar with the Wolves
so one of this is probably a lesbian my money
is on Black Beauty so when I drink too much
tonight can I count on you to hold my hair
back if I puke hahaha [Laughter] [Applause]
poor Ben I don't know his real name in this
movie he wasn't accepted he's gotta probably
some Asian he's gonna be the villain watch
he's gonna like start his own or something
the dark side yes this is his origin story
and he likes Star Wars so you know it's like
the parallels Stacy The Trebles don't respect
us and if we let them penetrate us we are
giving them our power not a good enough reason
to use the word penetrate so
anything to confess it was an accident I turn
in your scarf and go lady you vomited on stage
you're being way too harsh and it is my job
to make sure that my soldiers are prepped
at go time with three Kick-Ass songs and there
are only four months until regionals so if
you have a problem with the way that I run
the Bellas then you should just
you know this is a list of all of the songs
that we have ever performed we only do songs
made famous by women there's nothing from
the century on here because we don't stray
from tradition time to mix it up if you want
to win the competition also wouldn't having
sex with the other team actually get in their
heads and be used as a weapon perhaps
ships
one [Music] [Applause] okay we will work on
that first thing next time she's so tight
for Jesse a musical boner I saw it at Hood
night it's distracting you're not the blossoming
you took an oath that oath cost you two girls
already today I'm pretty sure you need me
more than I need you me to my boss well done
I think we're gonna be akka awesome
why do they look like flight attendants I
don't know not paying for this let's go well
I hope you all remember the way you feel so
you will never gonna feel this way again God
your voice didn't sound aguilarian at all
I have nodes what oh my God I just have to
pull back Chloe this is horrible well at least
it's not herpes or do you have that as well
[Laughter] do you want me to get you lunch
probably lay off the burgers not gonna be
22 forever you know I think I'm good I love
that guy's body I want to be him I want to
score movies bring people to tears you know
blow their minds I feel like only music can
do that you must really sweep your girlfriend
off her feet oh I don't have a girlfriend
you have juice pouches and Rocky
you just happen to guess the biggest cinematic
reveal in history Vader in German means father
his name is literally Darth father oh what
is that real I didn't know that are you guys
getting ready for the Riff Off what the hell
is a riff-off exactly what it sounds like
this is West Side Story
ladies of the 80s
[Applause] this [__] is like so cool especially
like actually it was real life this does not
happen in college if it did though college
would have been way cooler um nice
[Music]
the negative side effects of medical marijuana
folks wow I thought that was good Sean's about
sex all of them Like a Virgin
[Music]
I've had goosebumps this whole time I had
to put the girl that got cut out oh [Music]
that brings out the man in me nicely done
get in the ref off yeah feels the very first
time oh [__] here we go [Music]
now put it down never slow the original rump
shakers what is she saying I don't know sorry
get down lost strictly busy don't play around
much ground got game by the pounds what is
Spooby doing in my body [Music] [Laughter]
[Music] [Applause] look at that what happens
when you break tradition I look how comfortable
she is they got the audience in with the
[Applause] dude they're just jealous enjoy
watching us win the iccas on the TV on a regional
cable affiliate I want to watch you watch
the end of this movie such a good movie you've
seen it right it's a little overrated yes
princess and a criminal does that answer your
question sincerely yours a little lucky game
yeah I thought he was being watched you're
missing me sorry
oh I knew it oh yeah no one could predict
it that is that is so me though when I get
too nervous and I'm like I mean let's watch
another one
I
think Becca should take my solo yeah Becca
would be excellent they might be shy and not
when I come forward and say they wanted a
solo
I would be happy to do it if I got to pick
a new song and do an arrangement well that's
not how we run things here you can sing Turn
the Beat Around and that's the last I want
to hear of this you are so annoying that Amy
you'll solo he was like weirdly okay with
getting insulted like that I would have been
like this you want to dress like a flight
attendant go for it that's what I would have
said she doesn't care enough man maybe it's
that she works too hard so she gets jealous
of her for not working or she's secretly a
great singer and is jealous acapella is once
again proven that it doesn't get better for
everyone After High School geez they're so
mean oh my God the Bellows are gonna have
like a Mean Girls moment that might provide
some [__] let's go see the Bellas mixing
it up it's a refreshing yet displeasing to
the eye
and Bella is for saying song
and all eyes will be on senior Aubrey Posen
she could toss some cookies at any moment
[Music] throw up again [Music] she makes it
through folks no cookie toss for them I got
like leg chills
[Music] [Applause] [Music] there we go laughs
[Music]
[Music] awesome
[Applause] [Laughter] I love that [Music]
now right around [Music]
God damn they're good oh that's right John
I'll have to excuse me
jeez
e [Music]
damn they're so good and then they obviously
won who else would win they're way better
[Music] the winner of tonight's Regional competition
defending
oh he's still a loyalist to them yeah even
after he was mistreated that way I wonder
what he's gonna do he's gonna do something
you know they're all from a television show
dude really
I love him so much
she's looking excited
what have you done
it looked pretty serious that doesn't mean
you call my dad who else was I going to call
okay why are you yelling at me I'm the only
one here I didn't ask you to be it's like
a [__] tournament
if you think I'm paying for you to go to La
after a stunt like this I'm not get in the
car you're not even gonna hear what I have
to say about this No not tonight just get
in why don't you speak up man literally there
was like 50 people fighting there's so many
people getting it she got friends
I want you to take the night shift play your
music the DJ at the garage does a brilliant
version of this but yours it's better just
gonna get pulled away from the occupant no
no dick B2 bomb I have the semi-finals tonight
I did not have you pegged as an acapella girl
it's because you don't know Becky like I do
see you tonight I don't think there's been
enough screwing time dedicated to this whole
like rivalry yeah maybe there were deleted
scenes or something triangle seems more just
like a line it just keeps like increasing
every time we check in and I'm like rarely
here Donald Slow Down slow down [Music]
that is cruel that's so mean
[Music] I'm sitting up [Laughter] [Music]
laughs
[Music] we're all singing Greg I'm sorry yeah
I was more like why are my nipples so hard
just chills this whole every time they break
into a song I don't know why we must love
musicals Greg it can't be you just feel the
Phantom of the Opera's next yeah I did yeah
it's right right Next Step because I got hit
by flying Mexican food oh she didn't put the
gas in the someone should have checked but
you guys are gonna get pitch slapped so hard
your man boobs are going to concave
[Music] pretty good I set fires to feel Joy
oh
good times
[Music]
I wonder if these guys are like a real acapella
group I'm sure one of them is [Applause] I
hate their outfits so much like please change
for at least one performance [Music] here
we go again looks like they're sticking with
what they know God damn it's so boring when
you do this [Music]
she can feel it just break tradition
oh oh she's getting a mischievous let's go
[Music]
she's gonna do remixes that everyone yeah
that like made me nervous though steak can
haunt you for the rest of your life and affect
your children facts
screw us up are you serious your grade a pain
in my ass and I know you're hooking up with
Jesse if this is what I get for trying [Music]
Bella that was so loud in my ear Craig oh
my God that's the benefit of now being here
instead of filming remotely from New York
come on Ben Platt go after her and sing a
song [Laughter]
okay High School the Bellas do not advance
and Senior Aubrey Posen loses her chance to
redeem herself from last year's puke All Is
Lost can't you walk slow man she had it started
off a loner and started to gain friends but
now she's going backwards to being a loner
yeah relatable
oh
my God she's finally getting what she wanted
but maybe is this what she really wanted that's
what she needs Greg I don't I don't think
so character Arc she's reminded me to reach
out through music oh yes that's true I didn't
even think that for some reason that but all
the obviousness princess does that answer
your question The Breakfast Club Fun Factory
the whole take they made her watch the entire
movie just to really get in the camera yeah
we need a very realistic take yeah yeah we
are from the Collegiate acapella Association
it has come to our attention that you are
not in college
oh they'll get another chance now we're breaking
into act three people let's go oh she looks
good there holy [__] yes thank you sir
why because she's winded Greg she was yeah
I prefer women exhausted she was in True Blood
season two I remember her now
[Music] [Laughter] I love that bird sorry
we will win without her you don't look hot
anymore
oh my god do you think there's gonna be a
woman in the room with him gargled a little
bit
because I probably couldn't do it again
oh he was watching a movie by himself so now
they can watch one together you push away
anyone who could possibly care about you why
is that I don't know he's like get therapy
yeah yeah Jesse Breaking Bad that's what it
is yeah I am the one who knocks
she said surgery [__] and Jessica and
Ashley it is like you haven't been here all
year long have we really we've literally been
here the whole time [Laughter] Chloe could
you please get your head out of your ass it's
not a hat why don't they just kick her out
dad
oh I like it was listening uh this is about
the Bellas getting into the finals we already
know what are they watching the weather all
right
dust lamps I leave for Los Angeles in a few
hours so let's get going but bumper what about
the iccas there this weekend I won that [__]
like 100 times so I'm out of here he's leaving
and then it's gonna be him there's gonna be
the leader I know
[Music]
you know he writes his own he knows someone
in a magical box if you they will definitely
not let you
just come on I'm doing this group so I could
hang out with a bunch of really cool chicks
and also because I was really sick of all
my boyfriends and I need to get away from
that I'm sure to listen to Becca oh so it's
my fault Aubry you're too controlling and
it's gonna ruin all of us this time I'm not
get down
[Music] here [Music] [Laughter]
it's like the Exorcist oh my God let it out
they're gonna slip in it and it's gonna they're
gonna like
oh do it
[Music] I wanted to say that I'm sorry and
I definitely shouldn't have left
I let you guys down and I'm really sorry [Music]
continuity issues I didn't see it when she
first stood up [Music]
okay I know that I've been hard on you but
I am my father's daughter and he always said
if at first you don't succeed pack your bags
[Music] I guess we don't really know that
much about each other I have a lot of sex
yeah we nice I see only because I just told
you
for the last two years I've had a serious
gambling problem one it started when I broke
up with my girlfriend well
hey my twin in the womb [Laughter]
they gave her the best luck [Music] what do
we do [Music]
it's so well done
oh her eyes her eyes make the stars look like
they're not shining her hair ah this is so
much better um [Music]
best move we've ever seen in a long time
this is cool they gotta have like a CD huh
oh yeah a CD guy still called him on Spotify
though yeah one two [Music] what was that
I don't know I've never made that sound before
is that you no it was the movie I thought
it was you no I have something that can help
us out excuse me [__] you don't need to
shout
she could sing baritone I swear to God I thought
that was you oh yeah
what the hell yeah [Applause] welcome to the
finals of the 2000s here we go here we go
here we go ready for it shut your eyes and
get rid of all the aqua Politics the Lincoln
Center here in the Big Apple and singing on
this storied stage is the dream of every I
hope those are all real acapella groups they
got to you know be in the movie yeah I get
a chance to shine
count down [Music] I
bet Pentatonix was in this movie and we just
didn't even notice it yep good luck thanks
you too
troublemakers have no idea what you're going
for but now they have been plot so sometimes
[Music] oh she loves him yeah
tonight
here we go here we go
I've got the magic in me oh look at them respect
[Music] oh I hope they win yeah
how about you with the eyes come on down to
the front and sit right here and don't be
shy so come on come on God damn this is done
so well [Music] [Applause] I got the magic
in me I wonder if Ben Platt did more like
behind the scenes and stuff for this movie
I don't know you know yeah okay let's just
smash this okay I don't know how they're gonna
beat it do you how are they gonna beat that
I don't have a white board to lay it out for
you but Don are those Bella uniforms and this
is a whole new look for them and it is hot
hot junk these girls could turn me [Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh this is great [Music] good the hell are
you doing in that audience yes
let's go that's such a boss move will you
call my name oh this is fantastic
[Music]
so they're gonna pierce my shirts
[Applause] [Music]
see her hair wasn't down and the other one
and now it's down and then it's not down they
just accept it okay
[Music] oh my God you ladies
[Laughter] [Music]
[Music] [Laughter] [Music]
oh [__] [Applause]
all right I see it yeah
[Music]
my eyes are watery yeah it's so awesome you
need tissues here I know I do this is amazing
I don't even know why I'm so moved to this
whole movie are you oh my God
[Applause] I love it Sally I love it
yeah that's what I'm talking about I launched
this year's auditions email a recent icca
National Champion winners get to pick the
audition song oh hell yeah
[Music] I know that was amazing you gotta
come back out here Sally I know it's just
not to say when we are zooming in together
[Music] I think she directed the second one
okay I need to see that that was incredible
that was so good I figured literally it was
so like I'm just so happy yeah that was amazing
you should do a musical series because I feel
like it removed my music you know what they
had the man that Kristoff packed some like
music and everything I watched these days
um the I think the uh they had that line that
he was that what's the freaking guy's name
the love interest I don't know I don't know
I just can't I just I don't remember his name
yeah it's called discount Dane Cook the whole
time um God he looks so familiar just making
sure there's no post credits and you never
know right yeah I wouldn't I would know how
that feels they had that he was explaining
that whole thing about you know um you know
music and everything just booing your emotions
and moving you to tears and all that stuff
right and sure yeah I can experience picking
up his name so we can be proper with this
and not get turned out for non-wing character
names hold on but I and I think this one Chloe
don't worry it's just God punishing you because
you're a ginger [Laughter] oh they did like
little ad-libs yeah the um the I think yeah
she is his name Jesse who's the actor look
him up we would have waited I just went up
here right there which would have waited one
second it would have appeared um Jesse Yeah
I think the movie was just so because yeah
like I mean sure it's predictable and stuff
and the movie's telling you it was predictable
like I thought that was the whole point of
that scene when they when they have the DVDs
and she's saying how movie's going you're
like yeah you know it's predictable so of
course it's gonna follow the structures and
everything it's gonna go the route you expect
it to go but they still made it unique in
a lot of the jokes that they did it was way
edgier than I expected yeah um what was the
point of the DJ now that now that we've seen
the whole thing I'm like he didn't come back
at the end there was nothing you remember
the whole like love triangle thing that was
like kind of weird like oh yeah well I think
that was just the path of I mean I think for
her character Becca it was just showing how
she would she thought she wanted a specific
path that this was the real path that she
a real calling no no but I meant the character
specifically who cares he was hot and had
abs and was great I was I thought that would
come back at the end for something so did
I but it did not but everything else came
back at the end like The Breakfast Club references
that was well done that was really well done
that was a great moment yeah it was and and
a great way for uh her to show how much she's
changed I don't know it's just like sweet
and cheesy this is the kind of [__] that
I'm out there crying on camera because something
is is just so that's what usually makes me
cry it's like the heartbreaking uh like that's
not heartbreaking but just the real touching
stuff that people do you know that's real
touching that's some touching ass [__]
right there I love it I love that movie it
was so fun you know this was one of those
movies that like everyone hyped up so much
because everyone loved this movie that that's
why I like put off watching it does that ever
happen to you when it people like hype it
up so much that you like don't want to watch
you see the list of movies I have that I gotta
react to yeah definitely lived up to it just
because of how different the dialogue was
it was fun to watch like there were moments
around like the puke moment where that thing
fell you know that you're just like God that
was hilarious you know I I did not know it
was an acapella movie I I knew I knew it was
something to do with music because it's called
pitch perfect yeah and people have always
said like Anna Kendrick's a great singer so
I was like all right I'm assuming that yeah
there's some type of musical I I thought they
were I I had no idea what it what it was about
I had never seen like a trailer or images
or something like that I saw a trailer for
Pitch Perfect three but I don't think that
communicated to me that they deal with acapella
so um and that was I saw like one time years
ago so yeah when this movie started like oh
[__] does it knock up and I love acapella
like who doesn't love good good because if
you didn't what's your favorite acapella song
Greg uh I don't know any original acapella
no no I meant like what's your favorite rendition
of a song of an object my God I have one you
have a specific one what Pentatonix did Kanye
West's coldest winter is it pronounced Pentatonix
yeah I'm just no Pentatonix yes I don't know
why I enunciated just now pentatonic that's
how it's spelled Pentatonix but I just say
Pentatonix Pentatonix is Pentatonix yes I
don't know why I just was like Pentatonix
yeah you should listen to their uh Kanye West
uh version like yeah coldest winter on their
Christmas album I think it's gonna promote
Kanye West on this channel dope he's the he's
the personality I'm striving to be
and I think it was interesting watching this
because I don't mind Rebel Wilson um I've
seen a bunch of Rebel Wilson [__] after
this movie which is the movie that made her
like really I know this is the one that made
her like really famous and then I kind of
started seeing Rebel Wilson when she went
through that phase that everyone goes through
where it's like suddenly people really are
annoyed by Rebel Wilson all the time just
because she pops up and kind of does the same
kind of shtick all the time and then people
started going back to liking her again yeah
because she also like came out about how she
she was annoyed herself that she kept getting
like the fat funny character roles you know
yeah she was like uh what is she British Australian
whatever foreign not American version of Melissa
McCarthy herself like later was trying to
like break out of that type which Hollywood
yeah kept putting her in but she has a specific
kind of humor um I could see why this movie
made her real like way more on the map like
because it's cool that she gets to not only
done atmosphere a comedy but also demonstrate
her like singing capability she sold this
show and a lot of one-liners in this movie
and there were other characters like the silent
Asian girl that was like so funny I just like
what this movie was so much funnier than I
said yeah me too I thought it would just be
uh just a movie proven for female audiences
I really I just also really like it because
like there's not many movies that there's
all girls that has this amount like this great
humor in it you know mean girls that's why
it's also cool that McLovin was in this movie
because like yeah it's kind of like uh it's
cool just to see an all girls movie it's really
funny um like we got our super bad moment
I guess we did get our super bad moment yeah
it was it was funny and it was and and the
the directing and editing of the musical numbers
was so well done yeah it was like watching
a Pentatonix music video besides but the way
they would do especially in the in the training
sequences and stuff like that that was and
I was just an admiration of knowing like being
aware of some of these people who I only know
as actors and not musical performers and then
seeing just how much work they put into like
I'm watching this going I'm like it's a time
did it take to choreograph this choreography
all the sinking it's a lot of lip syncing
it's a lot of meshing of different songs like
remixes too and then imagine too the legalities
behind that like having to get every song
cleared and like I wonder how much true paid
for all the copyright stuff that's crazy well
I wonder because it's a universal movie so
they probably own a lot of it yeah they probably
had a lot of umg music which is the best company
on YouTube We love you umg they always they're
always like yeah the five two seconds plays
in a trailer you can keep it they're never
just we own your whole video now even though
you muted it yeah they're great um yeah I
thought Anna Kendrick was awesome too is this
the movie that made her like a lead performer
yeah I'm assuming yeah like a lead in general
she's I mean anytime she pops up in anything
it's weird she's in so much but like as a
celebrity she's not really like there's she's
so such an unproblematic Queen you know just
you never really see her in the tabloids oh
and the reoccurring motif of the uh the the
the commentators was his name John something
oh man look his name I want to make sure I'm
getting this [__] right attempt to Anna
Kendrick and not they Pitch Perfect um Elizabeth
Banks and uh what is what is John Michael
John what is his [__] name
what is it do you know it I know who you're
talking about but he's John Michael Higgins
that's his name yeah John Michael Higgins
and Elizabeth Banks they're great oh my God
they were hysterical I think Elizabeth Banks
is such a still to this day I mean she's been
becoming more of a director uh and she still
does stuff in front of the camera but I think
she's like an underrated comedic Talent uh
and then this this movie just shows that off
so much okay we gotta look up where it is
Skyler Aston guys from because damn I just
kept looking at his face going I've seen this
dude in something else oh it's facial hair
maybe we would know because I just saw a picture
of him a facial hair and he looks let's see
oh crazy ex-girlfriend God damn it he was
the he was Greg and crazy Have You Seen Crazy
Ex-Girlfriend you guys have not seen crazy
X you oh my God it's brilliant have you seen
any of it I know what it is you haven't even
seen him like one Emmys right you haven't
even seen like the musical numbers I've seen
a few um I have seen a few uh because I I
had an ex that watched it crazy ex-boyfriend
actually hey it's just a movie I mean a show
so you would love that show I know it is so
inventive and and I was hoping the first and
it's like deep too but hilarious how many
seasons there's only three but every every
episode there's not a lot of episodes there's
like a difference kind of music for every
episode like yeah yeah they're very creative
and they mix up the genres um and yeah I've
heard it's incredible I definitely need to
watch it because I love anything with music
and he plays a character uh in one of the
later Seasons like he replaces a character
um character yeah he's a character character
and that was that's where I've seen him from
that's right that makes sense because he sings
and [__] in there yeah it looks like he's
doing all he does trolls as well he's also
in trolls yes the new one or tro the show
and then
uh yeah he was good he was really nice he
was really nice yeah in that show he plays
like nice likable guy yeah yeah he's good
at that he's good at playing Knights like
a boca Adam DeVine have you seen that movie
where like he tries to get with this the girl
like he goes back in time to constantly try
to get with his friend no he's in that movie
he's a lead in it he's really good the butterfly
Factor no that movie is so fun but yeah guys
this was a great great cast of characters
yes some of some of the the only bit that
I thought was weird was the thing with the
room shower the shower
I thought that I didn't quite understand the
choices for that bit I thought that like she
was gonna be a singer and then like join them
or something like she was like jealous of
her or something like you're that never came
back at the end either like it was the point
of that I didn't understand a lot of the the
I didn't quite find Detroit it's not I didn't
understand it was like there must have been
so many deleted scenes the choice for it didn't
feel strong to me and it it just rang as a
little weird and then it didn't uh and it
just says have a good spring break I'm like
I guess they get along now or something I
kind of shipped Anna Kendrick and Brittany
Snow together you know I thought they were
yeah I thought they would have been excellent
but yeah all the other everyone in the in
the team of the Bellows were so were wonderful
they were all they did a perfect podcasting
yeah yes this was diverse and a lot of ways
um yeah musical numbers are amazing everything
about this movie I thought was great yeah
I I really enjoyed this movie a lot I had
so much fun it was like a surprisingly fun
yeah it was a fun movie to watch yeah because
sometimes when we when I when we film here
especially when I got people who are filming
like a Sally knows the situation today I was
like yeah just come over uh and then we'll
let's just look what do I got so and then
yeah I like to make it a little spontaneous
sometime and to find the spontaneous decision
that was about embracing spontaneity this
was the perfect choice Perfect Choice pitch
perfect perfect choice not a perfect movie
but um but for what it sets out to do it's
like near perfect the pitch was perfect ah
well done yeah well done and everyone on Rotten
Tomatoes likes it too except one person who
probably hates music and hates themselves
and you know and what's refreshing about watching
this movie to me as well see why they got
her for trolls too because for sure because
they kind of do like a similar thing with
their songs and [__] um
that's a great trip I didn't expect to love
that either and I was like this is a really
fun movie um the the a lot of times like people
might complain about the use of familiar songs
and [__] that plays on Nostalgia and this
movie manages of course to hit that note
however Beyond just hitting a familiar note
they've they find ways of making of like Reinventing
and making it really creative and super engaging
well they added in a lot of this the popular
songs when this movie came out at the time
and mixing that with the nostalgic 80s deal
like there were a lot of 80s songs in this
movie God this movie's 11 years old I love
80s music I feel like this movie just came
out like a couple years 11 years old I'm old
you are old and you're a woman so I'm kind
of times up by two
I started out you put our lighting Greg you
can see my wrinkles you look great Sally people
are gonna love the way you look right okay
yes comment about Sally's looks in this video
and not about her personality yeah guys okay
someone needs to comment and it needs to get
a lot of likes and I need Greg to do The Cup
Song from this movie like we should do the
cup song challenge it's like a challenge that
was like a popular thing yes it still is like
people still do it yeah I've never seen it
yeah really well they're banning tick tock
the government good thing we have YouTube
yeah I'll do the cup thing here do the cup
challenge whatever the cup challenge this
thing we should both do it and see who does
it perfectly pitch perfectly oh I can't wait
to watch the second one yeah you gotta come
back out here you gotta pay money fly out
here literally my mom I like FaceTime her
today she's like you can just fly out there
whenever you know like you just go to LAX
[Laughter] and uh and I won't pay you anything
that's fine that was amazing I was so surprised
Sally I'm glad we chose this one me too this
is probably it's probably out of all the ones
we've covered of the movies we've covered
together this is probably the most the most
fun one I would say I would say we've had
odd choices we've had really weird ones that
are like this is fun but it kind of tips some
of them dip in and out yeah Spaceballs was
hard for us grown-ups like we did grown as
time like we were fun but this was like oh
man I love this is the first one by surprise
many times and I don't think we had seen a
movie yet that had done that for us I also
cried so or I laughed so hard I cried in the
beginning and that was awful because I just
did my makeup and I was like I can't there's
no tissues that that was a great spontaneous
moment uh I think this is the first time we
watched together but we loved it yeah yeah
like genuinely loved it yeah oh what a blast
what a blasting blast of a situation well
thanks for watching guys thanks for being
here follow Sally she's a gem
Cherry Bomb I know Cherry Bomb you get do
you get Ever ashy knees no I get ashy knees
it's no problem I actually have a scar there
and I keep forgetting like I can see it on
camera but I don't know if it actually I ate
[__] as a kid off a bike like you ate
bad food while on a bike no I like had a bike
accident and like a third person oh like second
grade uh it was pretty gnarly um yeah so that's
from that it was like it was like all this
and then all I literally see nothing really
this right here it was like a big chunk just
taken out of my skin so you can see like a
circle there that's white that is so not noticeable
yeah I mean it's obviously like gone down
over the years they're there I'm right here
and I can tell you there's like nothing there
it's a contrast on your TV it's like you can
like see it right there it'll be clearer on
the camera camera yeah the camera that shoots
us yeah the shooting of the camera [Music]
poison specifically designed to kill Cusco
oh I missed you Craig I miss you too Sally
anyway guys follow Sally keep a lookout for
a Spider-Man short film she's gonna also try
to like show me that would look so good she's
gonna drop all her Marvel movie reactions
at once you know what we should do we should
we should have you film all hours just hours
I'm so down and then I'll tell my boss that
my flight's canceled and I'll just do all
the movies here I'll only show your reactions
to the like the last five minutes of each
one of them yeah
Sally choice I'm mine blamer all right guys
thank you for being here you check us on patreon
leave a like
[Music]